let's cool down some water by boiling it
the water in this Beaker is hot but it's
not boiling because the molecules in the
beaker don't have enough kinetic energy
right now to rapidly fight against the
air pressure from the outside that's
squeezing them into a liquid state but
let's put them under less pressure I'm
going to suck some of the water up into
this syringe and then I'm going to seal
the syringe with some transparent tape
right over the hole perfect nice and
airtight now when I pull down the
syringe the air pressure inside will
drop and many of the liquid molecules in
here will be able to fight against that
lower pressure and become a gas oh yeah
look at that the water is boiling this
is literally boiling water but we have
not warmed it up at all in fact now that
it's boiling it's actually colder that's
because the temperature of this water is
just the average kinetic energy of all
the molecules in the sample but by
boiling it like this we've allowed those
molecules with the highest kinetic
energy to escape as a gas so what's left
in liquid form are actually colder
molecules on average